it's time now for cbs morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your life a little bit easier
all at exclusive low prices these may
just become essentials in your daily
life to start shopping now scan the qr
code on your screen i'm serious go ahead
scan the qr code on your screen you can
also visit cbsdeals.com
lifestyle expert elizabeth warner is
here with some innovative gadgets that
may help us sleep better and get ready
for that summer road trip good morning
how are you doing good morning i'm will
thank you for having me of course so so
let's here let's start with a gadget um
that we can bring along on road trips
it's called the jump start that's right
oh i'm gonna hand this to you right away
okay this is amazing this is a safety
tool for your car and for at home it's
got 10 amazing features so starts off we
can actually
one thing we can actually jump start
most cars v all the vehicles you can
imagine your suvs even a boat a lawn
mower it plugs right in there you're
able to jump start it's got enough power
to do that but not only that if you look
at the bottom there again you're going
to see two usb ports those are fast
charging usb ports so we can charge all
of our devices on the go busy day
no time to plug in traveling with kids
exactly power outages it looks like a
flashlight it is a flashlight also so
you can turn that flashlight on high
beam low beam flashing lights red
flashing lights and as a safety device
it has a reflector strip that's bright
i can't see but it also has a reflector
on it and okay something happens
notifying people oh really
an audible alarm on the bottom there as
well on batteries or you charge it so
this one actually runs on batteries but
you can charge it right in through your
car or at home that is awesome
so it's pretty amazing all right so much
lots of lots of excitement with that
because you think about i've got four
kids they all drive they all have one of
those in their cars so now as a parent i
have that peace of mind my 18 year old
just started driving four kids and
they're all driving wow yeah were you a
teenager i was not but thank you okay
what does that one cost oh this one yes
so it's 139.99 normally today
79.99 that's 43 percent off okay
exclusively here okay so all right let's
move on to maybe that's what we call a
more great deal a deal that's right so
okay this is gonna help you cool off
these are all items to help us cool off
they're leaders in that cooling
technology they are globally known this
is an actual fan so what we do with this
we pop in four batteries we take the ice
pack that comes with it throw it in the
freezer that is going to go directly
into what looks like this big cup but
i'm going to pick it up and i'm going to
turn it on you can actually adjust the
stream with your finger and you can go
high or low in this imagine it fits in a
cup holder you can bring it in the car
throw it in the stroller take it with
you everywhere bring it to the beach i
actually use it when i want my exercise
equipment at home i'll see you guys
so it could be good if you had a friend
that had hot flashes oh hello i'm your
friend i'm your friend i'm your friend
you can you can turn that on your friend
too
i'm your friend so now this is another
great one first these actually come
together this is the actual cooling
towel so all we do is we place it in
water once we do that within 30 seconds
it's going to drop in temperature about
30 degrees cooler
than average body temperature so you can
wear it golfing you know hiking
how much was this family so they
actually go together the fan and the
towel so normally 49.98 today
24.49 that's 51 off the tube a lot of
athletes use that towel yeah and they
they would love that right
oh sorry there is a hat as well and that
one is the same way you actually just
put it in the water you're going to
squeeze it out put it on your head not
only cooling but it's going to help you
with the uvb and uva rays and the hat's
normally 19.99 today just ten dollars
i'm sorry what is this is part of this
oh this is this oh these two go together
okay got it i'm sorry to keep stepping
on everybody but i'm very excited about
this because this is a device as i
understand it's going to help people
stop snoring which yes if you live with
a snorer and i'm not saying katie
turner's
a lot of people do my mom's doing bad no
i do not i i sleep like the dead however
i mean you it can lead to all kinds of
problems right people sleep in separate
bedrooms because they're snoring that's
right
that's right so smart nora when you get
this home you're going to place this
inflation device into your own pillow on
the bottom then next to it here you'll
see there it is it looks like a mouse
that's actually a listening device and
it's going to detect when you snore as
soon as it detects it this will slowly
inflate
and deflate and that actually moves the
head and stimulates those neck while
you're sleeping while you're sleeping
yeah but it's very slow and gentle flap
in your like throat that's right the
noise yeah so then once you stimulate
those necklaces
normally it's 399
today it's 299 a hundred dollars off
it's a 25 saving and it will save your
marriage
purchase anything that you just saw scan
the qr code on your screen go ahead you
can also visit cbsdeals.com